[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
عشيه ذكرى اول رصاصه لحرب اوكرانيا الصين
تصيغ مبادرتها للحل وثقل اوروبا يهجر
غربها الى شرقها
والعربيه ترصد بدايات الازمه من ذاكره
قرينه زيلينسكي وتتلمس سيناريوهات النهايه
مع عقل بوتين
تركيا تان الزلزال ضرب اساسات صناعه
النسيج والسجاد والصلب وباغه الاقتصاد في
اكثر اوقاته ضعفا
ولدينا ايضا
سعيد يؤكد ان تونس تسير الى الامام ولن
تعود للوراء ابدا وواشنطن تربط المساعدات
بالتقدم الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
ساعات على الذكرى الاولى لانطلاقه الحرب
في اوكرانيا تلك التي تسميها موسكو عمليه
خاصه وتسميها كييف عدوانا ويصطف اغلب
العالم باستثناء الغرب حائرا وخائفا من
التداعيات على اقتصاده وغذائه فما الذي
يقدمه المتحاربون من تطمينات لا شيء روسيا
تتوعد بنشر اسلحه نوويه خارقه
تتعهد بالنصر
اذا تعهد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بان تولي بلاده اهتماما متزايدا بتعزيز
قواتها النوويه وذلك عبر نشر صاروخ سارمات
البالستي العابر للقارات هذا العام بعد ان
تاخر نشره كثيرا بالاضافه لغواصات النوويه
جديده ولوح بوتين بتقويض اسس الحد من
الاسلحه النوويه ما لم يتراجع الغرب عن
التدخل في اوكرانيا وفي خطابه لمناسبه عيد
حماه الوطن قال بوتين ايضا ان موسكو
ستواصل ضمان سيادتها عبر تطوير اسلحتها
[موسيقى]
وفي سياق الاتهامات الروسيه ذاتها قال
وزير الدفاع
ان الغرب استخدم اوكرانيا لمحاوله تفكيك
روسيا مضيفا ان هذه المحاولات ستكون
نهايتها الفشل وشدد شيجوع على ان الجنود
الروسي يدافعون عم دفع عنه الاجداد واجداد
الاجداد
اما سياسيا فقد حملت الخارجيه الروسيه
اوكرانيا والغرب مسؤوليه فشل التسويه وقال
نائب وزير الخارجيه ميخائيل جالوزين ان
احتمالات التوصل الى تسويه بعيده بالنظر
لتصريحات التي تعبر عن عزله كامله عن
الحقائق معتبرا ان الحوار معه صعب بسبب ما
وصفه باعتماده المطلق على الغرب وحدد
جالوزين شروط التفاوض وهي اعترافك والغرب
بالواقع الجيوسي سياسي الحالي والاعتراف
بالمناطق الروسيه الجديده والقاء سلاح
في المعسكر الاخر وعشيه الذكرى الاولى
للحرب قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان بلاده ستنتصر على القوات الروسيه واضاف
في بيان على منصات التواصل ان كيا لن
تنكسر وانها في طريقها للنصر ومحاسبه من
جلبوا الحرب اليها
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس الوزراء الاسباني
للتاكيد على ان حديث الصين عن بلاده قد
يكون خطوه اولى للوقوف بجانب العداله
السابق لاوانه الحكم على خطه السلام
الصينيه اعتقد بشكل عام ان حقيقه ان الصين
بدات تتحدث عن اوكرانيا وبدات بارسال بعض
الاشارات ليس بالامر السيء من المهم
بالنسبه لنا ان تكون جميع البلدان الى
جانبنا الى جانب العداله ان تتحدث الصين
عن اوكرانيا هو الخطوه الاولى وهذا امر
ليس بسيء
وكان نائب ممثل الصين في الامم المتحده
قال انبيكين ستطرح عما قريب ورقه حول
طريقه تسويه الازمه منتقدا ارسال الاسلحه
الى اوكرانيا
الازمات مهما كانت عميقه يمكن حلها بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه في نهايه المطاف ندعم استئناف
روسيا واوكرانيا الحوار المباشر في اسرع
وقت ممكن ووقف اطلاق النار والاعمال
القتاليه ووضع ذلك اولويه ويجب ان يبذل
المجتمع الدولي جهودا مشتركه لتسهيل عمليه
السلام الواقع اثبت ان ارسال الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا فقم النزاع ولم يجلب السلام
وندعو ايضا الى التخلي عن استغلال
العقوبات الاحاديه وان يكون البديل العمل
على تعزيز سبل الحوار الصينو لطالما لعبت
دورا بناء وستصدر عما قريب ورقه حول طريقه
تسويه الازمه واحلال السلام في وقت مبكر
الى هذه الصور مباشره لاضاءه معالم عالميه
بالعالم الاوكراني الليله ذكرى الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الذكرى الاولى تحل
غدا اذا نحن نتحدث هنا عن الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير قبل عام تماما بدات هذه الحرب
التي تسميها روسيا عمليه خاصه
واكياف والغرب يسميان يسميانها عدوانا على
اوكرانيا طبعا هذا برج ايفل في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وقد اضاء
بالوان العلم الاوكراني اضافه الى مباني
ومعالم اخرى في اوروبا في البرتغال تحديدا
هذه الصوره تصلنا منها اضافه الى معالم
اخرى قد يتسنى لنا لاحقا عرضها عليكم
لكن بينما يتعهد زيلينسكي بالنصر ويرحب
بخطوات الصين سردت جورنال ضمن تقرير لها
الاخطاء التي وقع فيها الرئيس الاوكراني
قبل الحرب وبعدها
هنا في الجنوب الاوكراني وتحديدا في منطقه
خيرسون وقف الرئيس الاوكراني قبل عام يهدئ
من هلع مواطنيه جراء الاخبار عن الحشود
الروسيه على طول حدود البلاد
اليوم وبعد عام من الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تعود الاصوات لتذكير الرئيس
الاوكراني بما تسبب به للبلاد ليس كمسبب
للحرب بل على تجاهله الاعمى للتحذيرات من
غزو روسي كان وشيكا ومن الاخطاء التي
اعادت البلاد الى ايام الحرب العالميه او
اسوا يتذكر الاوكرانيون جيدا كيف وقف
رئيسهم هنا يدعوهم لعدم الضعر كان ذلك قبل
ان تصبح المنطقه باكملها بيد الروس فيما
عدا المدينه
يجب ان اتحدث مع شعبنا كرئيس واقول للناس
الحقيقه والحقيقه هي ان لدينا معلومات
مختلفه لكن افضل صديق للاعداء هم
المذعورون في بلدنا وكل هذه المعلومات
تساعد فقط فيه خلق حاله الذعر ولا تساعدنا
نحن
وحكومته كان منشغلين بملاحقه الخصوم
السياسيين بتهمه الخيانه امر اثار استياء
الحلفاء الغربيين حينها وعندما بدات الحرب
لم يجد الاوكرانيون ما يدافعون به عن
انفسهم ورغم الحرب عاد الفساد ينخر حكومه
زيلينسكي وطفت على السطح قضايا فساد
مرتبطه بكبار مسؤول الحكومه والجيش اعترف
بها الرئيس في العالم
اليوم شهد الاوكرانيون مجموعه اخرى من
القرارات بشان الموظفين الفاسدين اؤكد على
اننا سنستمر في العمل على اي قضايا داخليه
تعوق الدوله الاوكرانيه من اجل الدفاع عن
البلاد والجهود المبذوله للتقرب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي رغم التاييد والتعاطف
الدولي للنسكي لا تبدو اوكرانيا بين حرب
وفساد باحسن حال في عهده ليس بسبب غزو
روسيا بل لان اداره لا تشبه التمثيل
والكوميديا وهو ما يقوله منتقد ومعارضوا
الرجل
في اول مقابله من نوعها لوسيله اعلاميه
عربيه قالت سيده اوكرانيا الاولى
لا احد يجهزها كسيده اولى في زمن الحرب
مضيفه انها تبذل كل جهدها كما كل
الاوكرانيين للانتصار في هذه الحرب
حسنا اولا وقبل كل شيء سابدا بحقيقه ان لا
احد يجهزك على الاطلاق كيف تكونين سيده
اولى خصوصا في حاله الحرب ولا احد يجهزك
لحقيقه انه يجب ان تكونين زوجه رئيس دوله
في حاله حرب ولكن كما قال داروين ليس
الاسرع او الاقوى من ينجو ولكن اولئك
الذين يمكنهم التكيف لذلك اعتقد انني اعمل
وفق متطلبات العصر حسب مقتضيات الظروف
التي نعيش فيها احاول ان افعل كل ما يجب
علي من اجل تقريب انتصارنا والشيء الاكثر
اهميه هو التحدث عن اوكرانيا
الاوكرانيين في اي منصه حيث اتيحت للفرصه
للتحدث
تنضم الينا منفذه العربيه ليال الاختيار
التي اجرت هذه المقابله اهلا بك معنا ليال
كيف يمكن ان تشرح لنا وللمشاهدين بعضا من
ظروف اجراء هذه المقابله قبل اي شيء اخر
لجهه طبيعه الحمايه الامنيه المرافقه
للسيده الاولى كيف وجدتها كشخصيه في ظل
ظروف الحرب عشيه الذكرى الاولى لها
شكرا لك طاهر يعني باختصار ممكن ان نقول
بانه من لحظه ان وصلنا الى ما يسمى هنا
المجمع الرئاسي حيث الرئيس السيده الاولى
معظم الوزراء موجودين هناك داخل هذا
المشمع طبعا هناك نقطه تفتيش بعيده جدا عن
المجمع يجب ان تنزل من السياره وان تدخل
الى هناك فورما تدخل هناك طبعا الاجراءات
الامنيه التي تقام عاده ولكن ملفاتني هو
كميه اكياس الرمل الموجوده يعني ممكن ان
تكفي لمعارك لاشهر داخل المجمع خارج
المجمع على الباب اينما ذهبت داخل المبنى
هي ملفته جدا لدرجه انك تحس انك تشعر انك
داخل معركه ليس داخل مجمع رئاسي طبعا
الغرف فورمه تدخل من المدخل الرئيسي هو
معتم مظلم جدا لا ترى اي شيء يعني لولا
طلبت من احد المرافقين ان يضيء لنا لانني
لا استطيع لاصل الى الدرج الذي يوصلنا الى
المكان الذي كان من المقرر ان نجري فيه
المقابله
وضعونا في مكان ثم ننقلون الى مكان اخر
طبعا للاجراءات الامنيه ولكن يمكن القول
بانها سكنه عسكريه وليس مجمع رئاسي السيده
الاولى يعني بغرار كل الوضع الموجود كانت
مرتاحه جدا مرتاحه لكل ما تقوم به من اجل
اوكرانيا ولديها ثقه عاليه بان العالم
والمجتمع الدولي الولايات المتحده المجتمع
الاوروبي يريدون ويؤمنون بالقضيه
الاوكرانيه ولكن اللافت الذي ساكشفه معك
اليوم طاهر بان السيده الاولى تحضر لجوله
الى الشرق الاوسط هي قريبه جدا لم تقل لنا
عن توقيت هذه الجوله ولكنها قادمه الى
الشرق الاوسط لتخاطب زعماء العالم العربي
وتقول لهم كونوا الى جانب القضيه
الاوكرانيه وساعدونا بهذه المحنه لان
المرح قادمه صعبه جدا اذا سيده اوكرانيا
الاولى الى الشرق الاوسط قريبا لمخاطبه
زعماء الدول دول المنطقه في هذه الظروف
الحرجه التي تمر بها بلادها ليال اريد ان
اسالك الان كيف اختلف عليك المشهد بين
تغطيه يوميا لهذه الاحداث طوال عام على
الشاشه وبين وجودك هناك على الارض ولو في
اكياس فقط كعاصمه
اختلاف يعني كامل كامل كامل كامل صراحه
انا اتحدث بكل صراحه بدون اي يعني
تكلفه بالموضوع لكن قبل ان اتحدث عن هذا
الاختلاف ساخبرك شيء طاهر وهو موجود اليوم
يعني التقيت رئيس مجلس الوزراء وعدد من
الوزراء وايضا عدد من الكتاب والصحفيين
الاوكرانيين بان اليوم المعركه ليست فقط
ضد الروس هناك مقوله بدات بالعام 2014
واليوم يعني اصبحوا يرددونها بشكل كبير
بان الحرب الاوكرانيه هي ضد الروس هي
حربين ضد الروس وضد الفساد وبالتالي من
هنا يمكن يعني ان تتخيل مدى حجم العمل
الذي تعمل عليه الادارات الاخرى لا اتحدث
هنا عن وزاره الدفاع طبعا والوزارات
المشغوله بالحرب الوزارات الاخرى تحديدا
مجلس الوزراء وكل المعنيين بهذا الميلاد
بمكافحه الفساد لان اوكرانيا اليوم تطلب
قرض من صندوق النقد الدولي وهي يعني تدخل
مرحله جديده بمرحله التمويل ما اختلف علي
بانني كنت اظن عندما كنت خارج هذه المدينه
ان هناك نوع من المبالغه بالقول بان يعني
الروس او عفوا الاوكرانيين يفرض عليهم ان
يتخلون عن الثقافه الروسيه وعن اللغه
الروسيه وعن كل ما الى هلالك ما شاهدته
يعني بالعين المجرده وليس احد اخبرني اياه
هناك البعض يستخدم الجوجل ترانسليت او
يعني الترجمه على جوجل لكي ينقل لي الكلمه
بالاوكرانيه وليس بالروسيه لانه يريد ان
يتخلص من اللغه الروسيه يعني اليوم الشعب
ما رصدت من كل من التقيت بهم يقولون باننا
لا خيار امامنا الا المواجهه نريد ان نكمل
هذه الحرب الى النهايه حتى وان كنا نعلم
بان هناك حسابات سياسيه للغرب على حساب
اوكرانيا يعني تخيل يعني هم يعلمون وليس
لا يعلمون ولكنهم يقولون باننا امام امر
وسنواجه حتى النهايه تمام هذه ارض
بالنتيجه
باختصار شديد لانه انتهى وقتنا في خوف من
يوم بكره او من الايام المقبله والاسابيع
المقبله بانه تتغير فعلا طبيعه المعركه من
قبل الروس وتعود كاف الى الواجهه مجددا
هناك خوف موجود عند معظم يعني المواطنين
الروس حتى داخل الادارات العامه وزاره
الدفاع وغيرها بان يعني تكون جبهه الشمال
هي المرحله المقبله مع دخول الربيع لانه
طبعا يعني سمامه تقارير عده وشاهدنا تقرير
عده عن التحضير الى هذه الاجابه حتى
الاوكران اليوم يحشدون بهذه الجامع تحسبا
لاي خطوه روسيه على ابواب الربيع هذا هو
الهاجس الاساسي اليوم اذا ما فتحت هذه
الجبهه هذا يعني بان كيف ستعود مجددا الى
واجهه المعركه وبالتالي نتحدث عن انها
ستكون كما المناطقه الاخرى المحاذيه
لروسيا
اسمح لي ان اقول لك ايضا
باختصار بالاخير المواطنين هنا يعيشون على
يعني على هذا الانذار الذي يطلق من من حين
الى اخر
يعني للمفارقه بانهم عندما تقول لهم هناك
انذار يضحكون انه تعودنا على هذا الانذار
وليس بشيء الجديد
شكرا جزيلا لك ليال الاختيار وغدا تغطيه
خاصه ومكثفه على العربيه في الذكرى الاولى
للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تحياتي اليك
نراك غدا ان شاء الله في مقابله خاصه
بالعربيه مقابله اخرى شدد الكسندر المفكر
الروسيه الذي يطلق عليه البعض عقل بوتين
شدد على ان روسيا اصبحت امام مفترق طرق
ولا يمكن لها ان تخسر الحرب او تتخلى عن
المناطق الجديده معتبرا ان خساره روسيا في
اوكرانيا تعني اندلاع حرب اهليه
في هذه الحرب التي نخوضها مع الغرب هناك
مفترق الطرق التالي انها حرب خطيره لدرجه
ان روسيا لا يمكن ان تخسرها بل يمكنها ان
تنتهي لا يمكن ان تقول حسنا سنتخلى الان
على المناطق التي استولينا عليها حين ذلك
سيحدث انفجار داخلي ستطابق روسيا في حرب
اهليه لا يمكن لروسي ان تخسر باي شكل لانه
بالتراجع خطوه الى الوراء سنتراجع الف
خطوه الى الوراء ستقاتل روسيا حتى النهايه
ببساطه لاننا لا نستطيع التوقف لا يمكننا
ان نخسر لن نكون راضينا الا عن تحرير
اوكرانيا باكملها من النخبه السياسيه
المواليه لحلف الناتو مهما كان الثمن
[موسيقى]
مقابله اجراها عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه في موسكو الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا غيرت الكثير على ارض الاخيره
وايضا في الجاره الغربيه لاوكرانيا بولندا
الان تنظيف بولندا لتصبح قوه عسكريه في
القاره العجوز بشراء احدث الاسلحه
الامريكيه بولندا وبسبب موقعها
الاستراتيجي وبسبب اهميتها في الازمه
الاخيره ما دفع محللين لاعتبارها اكبر
المستفيدين من الحرب الاوكرانيه بولندا
جزء من الجناح الشرقي للنيتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي كما انها المنفذ الاكبر من
اوكرانيا لايصال المساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه اليها خلال هذا العام زاد
بولندا مخصصات الدفاع باكثر من 4% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي كما وقعت قانونا
يزيد من حجم جيشها باكثر من الضعف ليصل
الى ثلاثه الف ثلاثمائه الف جندي اضافه
للتوسع في عمليات الشراء الاسلحه بكمي
ضخمه مقارنه بالدول الاوروبيه الاخرى ثوره
الانفاق العسكري في بولندا لخصها وزير
الدفاع ماريوش بلاتش تشاك في امله بان
تصبح بولندا اكبر قوه عسكريه بريه في
اوروبا كي لا تهاجمها روسيا الوزير اعاد
التذكير بان بلاده لطالما حذرت لسنوات من
التهديد الذي تشكله روسيا على دول الجوار
واستشهد بتحذير من الرئيس البولندي الراحل
في اعقاب غزو روسيا لجورجيا عام 2008
عندما قال اليوم جورجيا وغدا اوكرانيا
وبعد ذلك قد يكون موطني بولندا في مجال
التسلح يتم استبدال الاسلحه القديمه التي
تعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه والتي تم
التبرع بها لاوكرانيا بانظمه اكثر تقدما
من الناحيه التقنيه بولندا وقعت صفقه
باربعه مليارات و750 مليون دولار لشراء
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه في صفقه كانت قيد
الاعداد قبل حرب اوكرانيا كما اعطت
الولايات المتحده هذا الشهر الضوء الاخضر
لحزمه اخرى تصل قيمتها الى عشره مليارات
دولار بما في ذلك نظام الصواريخ هاي مارس
وصواريخ تكتيكيه طويله المدى بشكل عام
الاسلحه الامريكيه الجديده ليست الاضافه
الوحيده لبولندا اذ ان الولايات المتحده
او لها نحو 11 الف جنديه تمركزون شرق
بولندا علاوه على ان المقر الدائم لقياده
الفيلق الخامس الامريكي يوجد هناك
[موسيقى]
على الجانب السياسيه حولت حرب اوكرانيا
ميزان القوه السياسيه شرقا تجاه بولندا
وبالامكان ملاحظه ذلك في الزياره التي
اجراها الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
بولندا للمره الثانيه
بينما لم يقم حتى الان باي زياره الى
حليفتي واشنطن باريس وبرلين في خطاب القاه
في وارسو يوم الثلاثاء اشاد الرئيس بايدن
بولندا ووصفها بانها واحده من اعظم حلفاء
الولايات المتحده مشيدا باحتضانها للاجئين
من اوكرانيا وبدورها الرئيس في الرد
الغربي الموحد على روسيا رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ماتيوس مراوسكي تفاخر بهذا الامر
تفاخر في مقابله قال فيها ان مركز الثقل
انتقل الى بولندا والى دول اخرى في وسط
وشرق اوروبا اشار موراسكي ايضا الى ان
بولندا لن يتم الحديث عنها بعد الان على
انها مجرد عضو عضو شرقي جديد في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفي النيتو و سيتم الاستماع
للصوت البولندي اكثر حول ما يجري في
المنطقه مع ذلك وفي حين يعترف بعض الخبراء
خبراء السياسه الخارجيه بان بولندا اصبحت
محورا الا انهم قلقون من انها قد لا تكون
جاهزه تماما وقت الازمات بسبب المعارك
السياسيه المحليه قبل الانتخابات الوطنيه
في الخريف يضاف الى هذا الخلافات مع دول
الجوار البولندي ومنهم المانيا في بولندا
الحزب الحاكم القانون والعداله يعود لطرح
ملف التعويضات عن الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وهي مساله تعتبرها برلين مغلقه منذ فتره
طويله وفي هذا الصدد تصر بولندا على ان
المانيا لا تزال مدينه لها باكثر من
تريليون دولار بسبب المذابح التي تسببت
فيها المانيا النازيه الوضع الجيوسي في
اوروبا تحدث عنه تقرير
بوراس مكتب وارسو التابع للمجلس الاوروبي
للعلاقات الخارجيه
قال ان على القاده البولنديين الحرص على
عدم المبالغه في استغلال الاعجاب في
اوروبا بدوري وارسو لانه من الممكن ان
يتحول بسهوله الى غضب والسبب التجاذبات
السياسيه الداخليه في بولندا
[موسيقى]
معنا من باريس ساندرين الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اهلا بك معنا استاذ
في 360 كيف سيكون عليه الحال مع بدايه
السنه الثانيه لهذه الحرب على صعيد الدعم
الاوروبي الغربي
لاوروبا الشرقيه والى اي مدى ثبت انه
يستطيع ان يصمد ويستمر
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين طبعا
الحرب لها بالبدايه لها تكلفه والتكلفه
كبيره والتكلفه تتحملها بشكل خاص او
الخسائر منها هو البلد الذي تجري الحرب
على اراضيه وهنا المقصود طبعا اوكرانيا
اما تكلفه الحرب الاخرى على الحلفاء
اوروبا اليوم تتحمل الجزء الاكبر من نتائج
هذه الحرب لسبب بسيط هو ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الدعم الاول والذي يقود
كل التحالف الى جانب اوكرانيا ضد روسيا
بعيد كليا جغرافيا على الحرب وهو عوض ان
يتكبد الخسائر بالعكس بدا يجن الارباح
اولا من خلال بيع الغاز والنفط الى اوروبا
باسعار مضاعفه مما حمل رئيس الفرنسي الى
انتقاد والاطلاق صرخه
اتجاه الامريكيين والعمر الثاني هو طبعا
انتاج السلاح اوروبا الان تجد نفسها في
وضع حرج على المدى المتوسط او البعيد سوف
تبدا هي الاخرى تعاني بشكل اساسي من تبعات
هذه الحرب اولا على الصعيد المعيشي اليومي
والاقتصادي ارتفاع اسعار المواد الغذائيه
تكلفه
المعيشه
الطاقه ان كان المحروقات او الكهرباء كل
ما الى ذلك هذه امور بدات تنعكس عمليا
وجديا على وضع المواطن وعلى خزائن الدول
الاوروبيه الامر الثاني وهو الاهم السياسي
هو ان اوروبا اليوم تجد نفسها مره جديده
مضطره لان تكون تحت الكنب في الامريكي تحت
المظله الامريكيه من اجل حمايه تامين امنا
يجب ان لا ننسى ان الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل
ماكرون قبل اقل من سنتين حتى قال بان
الحلف الاطلس هو موت سريري صحيح لانه لابد
طبعا من ايجاد قوه اوروبيه مستقله اليوم
الحلف الاطلسي هو اقوى ما يكون عليه اقوى
من ايام الحرب البارده والكل يريد ان
يحتمي تحت مظله الحمض الحلف الاطلسي وطبعا
امريكا هي الرياضيه في هذا الموضوع بس
استاذ يعني انا سؤالي لك الان ما الخط
الاحمر الذي لن تتمكن اوروبا من اجتيازه
في السنه المقبله من الحرب وفي السنوات
المقبله فيما يخص العلاقه مع روسيا طالما
الحرب مع اوكرانيا او في اوكرانيا مستمره
ما هو الخط الاحمر يعني هي متضايقه وصلت
الى طريق تريد ان تحمي
معه ناسها وشعوبها ولكن هناك ايضا اثمان
ستدفع بالسياسه ان لم تصمت
اوروبا
بدرجه الاولى الان والرئيس الفرنسي عبر عن
ذلك قبل ايام قليله عندما قال بانه يعني
هم يريدون انتصار اوكرانيا هزيمه روسيا
ولكن من دون اذلال روسيا ومن دون تفكيك
روسيا بمعنى انه يترك الامر وهو يعرف بان
الاشجار الاوروبي روسيا بالنهايه لا بد من
اعاده ايجاد تسويه معينه تضمن التواصل
بينهما ان كان الحاجه الاوروبيه للطاقم
الروسيه او الحجر الاستقرار لانه اوروبا
تعي الان بان الحرب ممكن ان تصل الى الى
داخل اراضيها اوروبا الغربيه دائما الخطر
ياتي من روسيه او بسبب روسيا على امر
الثالث اوروبا تريد ان تقيم التوازن ما
بين علاقتها
وانتماءها او نوع من التبعيه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومن جهه اخرى
على ان يكون لديها بدائل او علاقه متوازنه
مع روسيا لذلك هي لن تقبل بان النظام
الروسي اولا لن تقبل بان تهزم روسيا داخل
روسيا تريد ان تهزم روسيا داخل اوكرانيا
مع تسويات يعني قد يكون لروسيا بعض
المنافع من هذه الحرب في المناطق التي
سيطرت عليها او التي اعلنت استقلالها
وانضمامها الى الى روسيا اذا الامر الاخر
وهو المهم بالنسبه اليها هي الخط الاحمر
بالنسبه مع روسيه لا يكون هناك تهديد
مباشره لدول داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي او
داخل الحلف الاطلسي لان عندها اوروبا سوف
تجد نفسها مضطره للدخول في مواجهه مباشره
عسكريه وهو ما تريد ان تتفادى تريد ان
تبقى روسيه شريك ان تبقى شريكا ربما
بالحصول على بعض التنازلات من بوتين او في
احسن الاحوال وافضل الاحوال ترانا على
المستقبل القريب عندما يتم تغيير النظام
ليس بالقوه وليس بالانقلاب ولكن عن طريق
انتخابات معينه هذا هو الواقع بالنسبه
لاوروبا وهي لا تريد ان تذهب في صدام
مباشر مع روسيا لانه سوف يؤدي الى انقسام
دول اوروبا يجب ان ننسى ان المانيا لديها
وضع خاص وعلى خاصه مع روسيا وبالتالي ايضا
قد يركز ايام من هذا النوع على علاقته
داخل اوروبا شكرا جزيلا على هذه القراءه
استاذي من باريس تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحل مغلقه
والشوارع خاويه حدادا على ضحايا اقتحام
نابلس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في تركيا قال وزير
الداخليه سليمان سويلم بلاده ستوسع تحقيقا
بشان مقاولين البناء المشتبه بانتهاكهم
معايير السلامه وذكر صويلح وانهما حددوا
هويه 500
مشتبها به حتى الان
واعتقلوا 160 فيما تتواصل التحقيقات مع
عدد اكبر بكثير
اربعه زلازل كبيره ضربت تركيا خلال الايام
الماضيه وتناولنا تداعياتها الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه الليله نبحث في الاثار
الاقتصاديه التي سينتجها الزلزال عشرت
مليارات دولار رقم مبدئي لحجم الاضرار في
المباني كاقل تقدير وهو الرقم الاكثر
تفاؤلا على فكره اضافه لسنوات من العمل
المتواصل المتوقع قبل عوده الاوضاع الى ما
كانت عليه قبل الزلازل البنك الاوروبي
لاعاده الاعمار والتنميه قدر ان الاثار
الاقتصاديه للزلازل قد تتسبب في خساره تصل
الى واحد في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي لتركيا صحيفه احوال تركيا تحدثت
الى خبراء اقتصاد ذكروا ان معدل النمو في
العام الجاري قد ينخفض الى 1% بعدما كانت
التحليلات تشير الى احتمال تسجيل نسبه نمو
تتراوح بين الثلاثه والثلاثه ونصف في
المئه ما يعني خساره تقترب من عشرين مليار
دولار
نمو التضخم ايضا في طريقه للارتفاع في
تركيا بعدما كانت نسبه التضخم الاخيره
المعلنه الشهر الماضي
58% نتذكر هنا ان نسبه التضخم تجاوزت
اواخر العام الماضي 80 في المئه مع سياسه
الحكومه لخفض اسعار الفائده كذلك يوجد
اجماع في التقديرات والتقييمات الاقتصاديه
بان تركيا ستواجه دون شك ازمه عمله جديده
بينما الليره شهدت سابقا هيارات متتاليه
كما نذكر بدءا من عام 2018 وفقدت قرابه
50% من قيمتها جانب اخر سلبي يتعلق بعجز
التجاره الخارجيه التركيه التي سجلت تركيا
عجزا قياسيا فيها بلغ 110 مليارات دولار
العام الماضي وتوقع بنك الاستثمار
الامريكي مورجان ستانلي ان تضيف زياده
الواردات في هذه الفتره عبئا اضافيا قدره
تسعه مليارات الى العجز
وسائل اعلاما تركيه تداولت الاثر
الاقتصادي للزلزال الذي كانت ولايه قهرمان
مرعش مركزه الولايات المتحده عفوا
الولايات التي ضربها الزلزال الاول تسهم
بنحو 10% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
وتتركز في منطقه الكارثه انشطه الزراعه
وتربيه الحيوانات والانتاج الصناعي قهرمان
مرعش التي كانت الاكثر تضررا تحقق منفرده
سته 36% من انتاج الغزل في تركيا بينما
ثلث الانتاج التركي من الحمضيات ياتي من
اضنه وفيها طاي نجد اكبر مصنع للحديد
والصلب بينما تبرز ولايات متضرره اخرى في
مجال السياحه وانتاج الحبوب والقطن وحتى
قبل الزلزال كانت تركيا تواجه معوقات في
الانتاج الزراعي في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه كالجفاف وتباطؤ الانتاج اضافه
لمشاكل تتعلق بالاعلاف اليوم ازاح الزلزال
الستاره عن وضع قاتم فمع المشاكل السابقه
ضرب الزلزال البنيه التحتيه الزراعيه
وتسبب في نفوق الالاف من رؤوس الماشيه
وبدايه حركه نزوح للمزارعين صحيفه احوال
التركيه نقلت عن خبير اقتصادي قوله ان ما
تحتاجه تركيا حاليا هو وضع استراتيجيه
انتاج متكامله لانعاش اقتصاديات المدن
المتضرره من الزلزال في الفتره المقبله في
محاوله للوصول الى وضع مقارب نسبيا لما
كان عليه الحال قبل الزلزال
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الخبير الاقتصادي
والتركيه رحمه انجيكار اهلا بك معنا
انجيكارا استاذ
رحمة هل هذه الارقام بالنسبه اليك واقعيه
منطقيه او فيها مبالغه
تركيا لملمتي
الاثار التي خلفها زلزال الماساوي على
تركيا فهناك عمليات تقييم مستمره
للدمار الذي
تسبب به
الزلزال على الاقتصاد تساهم
تقوم تركيا بانفاق خمسه.3% من اجمال
الناتجها المحلي على تفادي اثار الزلازل
وعلى عمليات اعاده الاعمار وهناك رقم قدره
80 مليار دولار امريكي
في التقارير الاوليه الذي يجب ان يكرس
لعمليه اعاده البناء
وهناك تكلفه لاعاده بناء المنازل التي تصل
الى 30 الى 40 مليون دولار وفقا لتقديرات
ستانلي
وعمليه اعاده البناء سوف تصل الى 25 مليار
دولار هذه الارقام
لم تاخذ في الحسبان
الضرر الذي تعرضت له الشركات التجاريه لكن
هناك لابد من ان نذكر ان خمسه ملايين شخص
الان باتوا
يعيشون باوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه
وقد اثرت عمليات الدمار على انشطه شركات
الامر الذي
يصل بنسبتهم من 0.3 الى 0.8 على اجمل
الناتج المحلي
وبالنسبه للشركات فهناك
اكثر من الف تسعمائه وتسعين مشروع صناعي
قد
تم تاثرها بصوره كامله وهي لم يتم اخذتها
في الحسبن وهي تسهم ايضا بواقع 3% في
اجمال الناتج المحلي
وقد انخفضت
وقد انخفضت هذه التقديرات الى حد كبير ولم
تعكس التقارير
حجم الضرر الكامل على وضع الاقتصاد
يوجد
اكثر من
شركه كانت تعمل في مجال الانتاج وفي
القطاع الاقتصادي كلها قد تضررت بصوره
كامله في ولايه مختلفه
الكل يدرك بان هذا الزلزال قد يكون هو
الاعنف من نوعه الذي ضرب البلاد منذ
قرن من الزمن
التاثيرات المباشره
لا يمكن ان
تصنف بانها متوسطه في ظل كل تلك الارقام
لانها
لانها لان زلزال قد ضرب مناطق حضريه
ومناطقه ريفيه بعيده وهي سوف تخلف وتلقي
بظلال لها على الوضع الاقتصادي
الخبراء الاقتصاديون هنا كانوا قدوا شددوا
على ضروره رسم سياسه اقتصاديه من اجل
اعاده البناء رغم كافه الظروف
القطاع الانتاجي
وتخلفه في ظل هذا الاوضاع قد يدفع بتضخم
الى مستويات عليا في البلاد ورفع اسعار
المستهلكين لدرجه غير مسبوقه في قد تصل
اكثر من عشرين في المئه على المدى القصير
البلاد بحاجه
الى ورسم ووضع تدابير سياسيه ونقديه التي
يجب ان تاخذ في الحسبان ضروره ارساء
الاستقرار في كافه المناطق كذلك واجهت
تركيا
متطلبات
الداخليه اقتصاديه تتوقف على حجم الاموال
التي سوف تكون مطلوبه لاعاده اعاده البناء
وقد تكون تركيا بحاجه الى تمويل خارجي من
مصادر خارجيه
وهذا وهذا سوف يكون
رهنا للاثار لنتيجه الاثر التي خلفها
الزلزال وكذلك يتوقع ان ان تتسبب
اثار هذا زلزال
بالحق اضرار على قطاع الانتاج الذي يشكل
2.9% من اجمالي الناتج المحلي
وهذا الدمار سوف يعرقل ايضا
النمو بصوره ملموسه هذه السنه تمام
على هذه القراءه استاذ رحمي انا مضطر
لمقاطعتك شكرا جزيلا على هذه المداخله
الليله معنا رحم انجيكارا الخبير
الاقتصادي التركي من اسطنبول تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن ثلاثه مسؤولين من
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل والسلطه
الفلسطينيه قولهم ان السلطه تهددت
بالانسحاب من قمه امنيه من المقرر عقدها
مع اسرائيل والاردن ومصر وامريكا بعد
اقتحام نابلس والذي اسفر عن مقتل احد عشر
فلسطينيا
[موسيقى]
واضمن محاولات احتواء التوتر الحاليه بحث
وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري ونظيره
البريطاني هاتفيا تطورات الاوضاع بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وشدد شكري على
دعم القاهره للتهدئه وتشجيعهم على العوده
الى المفاوضات وكسر جمود عمليه السلام
بينما عبر كلاب عن قلق بلاده البالغ
لتدهور الاوضاع الامنيه والانسانيه مؤكدا
العمل مع شركاء الاقليميين والدوليين
وبينهم مصر لاحتواء الوضع
في العربيه 360 ايضا قبل عام كانت تحذير
روسيا واليوم يتكرر ولكن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد خلال لقائه على ان تونس سوف تسير الى
الامام ولم تعود ابدا الى الوراء
قدنا السنسير الى الامام ولا عوده الى
الوراء ابدا
ونعمل عن قاده دوله التونسيه
وتمكين التونسيين والتونسيات من حقهم في
الحياه الكريمه
ومن حقهم في كل المرافق العموميه للدول
ووضع حدا لشبكات الفساد اليوم
قضيه تتعلق
بفساد ايضا في ولايه بن عروس للاسف في
ديوان الحبوب ولابد من ان يتحمل القضاء
دوره كاملا في مواجهه هذه الظاهره
هذا واستنكرت احزاب تونسيه معارضه استمرار
حمله الاعتقالات بحق سياسيين ونقابيين
وحقوقيين ووصفتها بالعشوائيه وجاء في
البيان المشترك لاحزاب التيار الديمقراطي
والقطب والعمال والتكتل من اجل العمل
والحريات ان الاعتقالات دليل على قصور
سياسه الرئيس التونسي
من جهته اكد السفير الامريكي الجديد لدى
تونس على ان الولايات المتحده تريد ان
تتبين توجهات تونس
وشكل الديمقراطيه فيها في المستقبل حتى
تحدد طبيعه المساعدات المطلوبه
من تونس البرلمانيه السابقه عبد العزيز
القطي اهلا بك معنا استاذ عبد العزيز كيف
يعني يمكن ان ننظر الى هذه الاجراءات التي
تستمر بها الحكومه والرئاسه مقابل سلسله
الانتقادات التي ذكرنا بعضا منها
شكرا مساء النور بطبيعه الحال مثل هذه
الاجراءات ومثل هذه القرارات التي تتخذ في
الايام الاخيره ستواجه ببعض الانتقادات
ولكن هذه الانتقادات هي من جانب من
يعتبرون انفسهم جرحها 25 جويليه 25 جويليه
الذي قطع مع مرحله
وقطعه مع عشريه سوداء كان الاسلام السياسي
هو المتحكم الاول في هذه العشريه في الحكم
في دواليب الحكم اخترق كل الاداره
التونسيه اخترق وزاره السياده اخترق وزاره
الداخليه اخترق وزاره العدل وضع يده على
مفاصل الدوله وتربع على عرش الحكم
واعطى رئاسه البرلمان في مده الاخيره الى
راشد الغنوشي الذي اراد ان يلعب دور رئيس
الجمهوريه والحاكم الفعلي في تونس مع كل
الجرائم التي اقترفها هو ومن معه في حق
الدوله التونسيه سواء كان ذلك على المستوى
المالي او على مستوى امن البلاد على او
على مستوى الارهاب الذي ضرب تونس في
العديد من المرات وكانت هناك اغتيالات
سياسيه وكان
بعض يسال الى اي متى تعليق كل ما يحصل في
تونس على شماعه الفتره التي حكم بها
الاخوان في تونس يعني بمعنى انه البعض يرى
انه كان يجب تجاوز هذه المرحله من فتره
منذ اجراءات الرئيس قيس سعيد والمضي قدما
يعني اما باتجاه الحسم والقطيعه مع تلك
الفتره بشكل نهائي لكي يتبين الناس اين هي
تونس الان والى اين تمضي او يعني المضي
قدما باتجاه مبادره انقاذيه اصلاحيه لا
تزال تلقى رفضا حتى الان
نعم لا يمكن الحديث عن مرحله جديده ولا
يمكن الحديث عن تونس جديده بدون تصفيه
التركه الثقيله العشريه السوداء وعشريه
الخراب التي تحدثت عنها لا يمكن ان تطوى
هذه الصفحه بدون محاسبه لا يمكن ان تطوى
هذه الصفحه بدون تحميل المسؤوليات لان حجم
الخراب وحجم الدمار الذي لحق الدوله
التونسيه في كل المجالات الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه السياسيه
الدوليه على مستوى العلاقات مع العديد من
الدول الاخرى لا يمكن اليوم ان يطوى او ان
يتم التغاضي عنه بجره قلم والمرور الى
مصالحه مصالحه مع من مصالحه مع من اجرم في
حق تونس مصالحه مع باعه ارواح التونسيين
مصالحه مع من سفره التونسيين وشباب
التونسيين الى بؤر التوتر من اجل ان يقبض
مقابل ذلك حفنه من المال
قابله ان يدمر الاقتصاد التونسي مقابل ان
يدمر الاداره التونسيه واجهزه الدوله
التونسيه حتى يفعل بتونس محراث والملفات
موجوده والملفات موثقه واليوم ما يقوم به
القضاء التونسي بعد ان تخلص من وضع اليد
الذي لحقه من الاسلام السياسي ومن حركه
النهضه اكبر دليل على ان هذه ملفات كانت
مقبوله على ان الاراده كانت من اجل قبل
هذه ملفات وعدم الخروج بها الى وعدم تحميل
المسؤوليات وعامدا بمعاقبه من اجرم في عقد
تونس
بعد ان تحرر
اعذرني على المقاطعه استاذ عبد العزيز
القطيع البرلماني السابق من تونس تحياتي
اليك
مباشره الى صهيب واخبار الساعه مساء الخير
صهيب ماذا لديك مساء الخير طاهر في
الصداره هذه الليله العوده عن الحديث عن
الوساطه الصينيه بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لانهاء الحرب زيلينسكي لديه موقف حياه
لهذه الخطه على ما يبدو اليك تفضل شكرا لك